[Music]  meagan Marco leaves London as boyfriend  Prince Harry attends a charity Christmas  party with William and Kate and the  Queen continues to celebrate her 90th  year this is a prince who wants the  world to see his very gorgeous  girlfriend and look just how happy they  are  Harry's girl Megan was snapped at  Heathrow Airport over the weekend after  spending a romantic week in London with  the prince  he spent the weekend with his brother  and sister-in-law they showed their  support for the heads together charity  at the group's holiday party the three  met with volunteers made crafts with  kids and helped honor members of the  heads together teams we can all play all  pause by talking and listening to each  other and helping each other find  support and check it this out Clarence  House shared this stunning portrait of  Prince Charles and Queen Elizabeth the  second over the weekend it was taken  earlier this year for the Queen's 90th  birthday  you  [Music]